si vous demandez mes amis avant qu'on
commence qu'on puisse se lever les uns
et les autres vous savez qu'en ce moment
se déroule la commémoration à nice pour
les victimes horrible de ces attentats
et je pense que c'est bien qu'on fasse
tous une minute de silence
merci à sans vous
savez là pendant qu'on se recueillait un
peu tous ensemble
je pensais à une une des familles de
chez moi qui a perdu c'est une famille
qui est très proche de moi qui a perdu
sa fille au bataclan qui était une
gamine resplendissante brillante 22 ans
je peux vous dire que quand vous
rencontrez le père et la mère qu'ils ont
les yeux vides qui regarde dans le vide
qu'on sent que la souffrance à tour en
place et qui comprennent pas comment
est-ce que ça peut arriver comment
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir une telle
barbarie c'est dur et je pense que c'est
bien que pendant tous ces moments on
essaie pensé d'abord pour les victimes
ceux qui restent ceux qui ont souffert
dans leur chair et qui ont perdu qui ont
perdu leurs proches et puis la deuxième
chose que je souhaite c'est qu'on
n'oublie pas parce que je suis frappé de
voir la vitesse avec laquelle dans notre
débat médiatique on oublie on tourne les
pages jusqu'au prochain attentat et
j'aimerais bien qu'il ait autre chose
qui se passe je vous en parlerai voilà
merci à tous pour eux pour les victimes
de nice merci
[Applaudissements]
bon vous avez vu un peu cette tribune
qui s'est considérablement améliorée
avec l'arrivée de laurence notre
secrétaire national qui s'occupe
notamment des français de l'étranger
vous applaudissez chaleureusement son
jacques on a des histoires communes avec
jean-jacques
savait à l'époque je m'occupais de la
politique de l'emploi et jean-jacques
était très active sur les missions
locales on a beaucoup travaillé ensemble
c'est notamment seulement un militant de
notre famille politique mais c'est aussi
pour moi un ami qui m'a accompagné dans
bien des engagements et je suis très
heureux qu'il ait pris cette tâche de la
primaire en plus ça l'obligé à être
objectif ce qui lui fait beaucoup de
bien un genre jacques on l'applaudît
très fort
[Applaudissements]
frédéric a fait du boulot je peux vous
dire en secrétaire départemental
extraordinaire quand même notre première
fédération de france
ici c'est un bonheur pour moi de l'avoir
à mes côtés c'est un directeur limpide
c'est un chef auprès de ses équipes pour
moi c'est un directeur qui est à mes
côtés extrêmement fiable et puis ça a
été surtout un travail remarquable d'un
redressement du parti ça il faut pas
oublier où en était il ya deux ans et
demi il faut pas oublié ce qu'était la
situation de notre parti il faut pas
oublier que le bateau prenait l'eau
difficile d'être crédible quand vous
voulez redresser la france et que les
comptes du parti sont dans le rouge
difficile de dire que on va arriver à
redonner un élan aux parties quand on a
un parti qui est divisé et déchiré je
vous en reparlerai le travail qui a été
fait pendant deux ans et demi par
nicolas sarkozy à la tête de notre parti
pour le remettre à flot lui redonner une
parole faire en sorte qu'ils soient à
nouveau sous dé faire en sorte qu'on
soit en ordre de bataille pour la
présidentielle
et qu'on ait la chance de pouvoir gagner
cette présidentielle
le travail qui a été fait pendant deux
ans et demi j'en suis fier et je les
assume c'est un beau travail qui a été
fait pour remettre notre parti et
qu'aujourd'hui on soit prêt pour cette
bataille
vingt mille vous êtes 20000 primo
adhérents
ça veut dire des gens qui avaient jamais
adhéré avant on a un taux de
renouvellement de nos adhésions qui est
excellent on a un pourcentage de
nouveaux adhérents alors qu'ils étaient
parfois des adhérents qui nous avait
quittés puis qui maintenant reviennent
qui est très bon et donc on a vraiment
un parti dont on sent que l'on sera prêt
pour l'après-primaire et je vais vous
parler de l'après primaire je crois
enfin dire un mot pour philippe goujon
et roger karoutchi
philippe goujon on a mené bien des
batailles ensemble très peu hein parce
qu'il est très jeune c'est un petit
jeune en politique comme roger pareil
mais vous savez à la fédération de paris
philippe huilée sur la ligne de front et
il n'a jamais perdu et il n'a pas perdu
parce que son quartier il le connaît son
arrondissement il le connaît il se bat
c'est un élu de terrain et moi j'ai le
plus grand respect parce que je me suis
toujours construit comme ça pour ceux
qui partent d'abord de la base et du
terrain quand vous avez des élus qui
parlent plus sur les plateaux télé qui
ne sont chez eux sur leur territoire ça
finit toujours mal philippe c'est
quelqu'un qui sait que la politique elle
se construit d'abord avec vous et j'aime
bien ça chez lui en plus de sa rectitude
d'anciens membres éminents de la
gendarmerie sur cette estrade vous avez
un policier un gendarme vous n'êtes pas
prêt de vous en sortir vos
applaudissements pour monsieur goujon
[Applaudissements]
bon et enfin roger un
amas péchenard ne l'était pas gendarme
si vous lui dites ça ça va pas lui
plaire
et vous avez à côté roger vous le
connaissez tous roger sénateurs
notre responsable sur les hauts-de-seine
une fédération qui fonctionne
admirablement et puis roger c'est
surtout l'amitié la fidélité vous savez
en politique c'est pas si courant un
roger c'est quelqu'un qui est toujours
sur le même chemin toujours la même
droiture toujours le même cap une
loyauté qui est absolument irréprochable
et ce léger sens de l'humour qui nous a
pas échappé et qui ne gâte rien quand on
a des convictions merci roger
alors une priorité une seule priorité y
en a pas deux il y en a pas trois il y
en a une seule du rassemblement encore
du rassemblement toujours du
rassemblement la primaire c'est très
bien la compétition c'est normal dans
notre famille politique on aime qui est
de la compétition mais pas du désordre
pas de la bataille interne pas des
querelles et mon obsession à moi c'est
ça je ne veux pas de divisions à
l'intérieur de notre famille politique
à l'occasion de cette primaire le débat
s'est bien passé pour être très honnête
si j'ai un conseil à leur donner encore
moins de petites phrases encore moins d'
attaques contre les autres exprimez vos
idées en positif plutôt que de passer
votre temps à critiquer ceux du voisin
exprimer ce que vous voulez proposer
plutôt que de critiquer ceux qui sont à
côté de vous la primaire doit se faire
en positif et nous dans notre famille
politique et c'est pour ça que nous
voulions continuer à vous rassembler à
être ici à être unis dans cette salle il
ya sûrement des gens qui ont des
convictions différentes sur cette
estrade on est avec des convictions qui
sont différentes et tant mieux mais ce
que je veux c'est que nous n'oublions
jamais cette idée nous avons infiniment
plus en commun que ce qui nous sépare
nous avons infiniment plus de points qui
sont nos points à nous qui sont nos
valeurs communes que ce qui nous divise
et nous oppose engagez vous votez
votez autour de vous convainquez dans
vos cercles parce que cette élection ça
doit être la vôtre ça doit être celle
sur laquelle les adhérents de notre
famille politique sont pleinement
investis porte à fond nos convictions
mais faites le sens critique et faites
le sans dénigrer soyez intraitable avec
tous les candidats qui pratiquent le jeu
des petites attaques notre obsession à
nous au sein de notre famille politique
c'est le 28 novembre c'est le jour
d'après la primaire ce n'est pas une fin
en soi la droite a une trop grande
responsabilité pour avoir le droit de se
déchirer le 28 novembre se veut un
vainqueur et je veux un rassemblement
et j'ai besoin de vous pour nous y aider
parce que vous savez comme c'est dans un
an c'est la campagne on s'emporte on en
fait un peu trop nous on doit pas
rentrer dans ce jeu là on doit être la
quille de cette primaire celle qui
permet au bateau de bien tenir au milieu
n'oublions jamais surtout ici dans ce
lieu ce que nous ont coûtés il ya trois
ans nos divisions et nos querelles
n'oublions jamais que pour la droite
c'est mortel et c'est mortel pour une
raison c'est que quand les français
souffrent il ne supporte pas de nous
voir nous diviser ils attendent de nous
nous opposions ils attendent de nous que
nous défendrons nos valeurs ils ne
veulent pas de bataille et de querelles
intestines parce que ça donne une image
pitoyable la droite c'est autre chose
c'est des valeurs c'est des convictions
c'est un rassemblement le 28 novembre
c'est un chef et dernière c'est une
équipe et pardon de le dire mais tous
ceux qui dans cette primaire nous
expliquent qu'ils vont voter à la
primaire mais qui ne se sentent pas lié
par le résultat du second tour c'est
inacceptable
quand on vote à la primaire on est
engagé par le résultat de la primaire
c'est tous unis sinon on reste chez soi
alors
mes amis quelle semaine
on finit par plus voir ce qui se passe
sous nos yeux
ce qui s'est passé la semaine dernière
dans ce quartier de la grande borne il
faut qu'on ouvre les yeux vous rendez
compte de l'état dans lequel notre pays
est tombé vous avez des caméras de
vidéosurveillance moi ma connaissance
les caméras de vidéosurveillance est
précisément fait pour qu'on n'ait pas
besoin de mettre deux policiers sur le
terrain et de leur permettre de ne pas
prendre de risques
non seulement ces caméras de
vidéosurveillance ont été attaqués
réattaquer mais maintenant france au
stade où on en est on met des policiers
pour surveiller les caméras de
vidéosurveillance qui surveille la rue
non mais vraiment comment est-ce qu'on
peut finir par accepter un tel niveau
d'effondrement de l'autorité régalienne
ainsi il faut bien comprendre ce qui
s'est passé on en a beaucoup discuté
avec frédéric vous avez une bande de
combien frédéric 15 20 personnes
dix-neuf personnes qui arrivent
qui fracturent les vitres qui brisent
les vitres des voitures pour être sûr
que les cocktails molotov qu'ensuite ils
vont profiter atterrissent bien à
l'intérieur de la voiture qui ensuite
attendre que ça prenne feu bloque les
portes hier pour s'assurer que les
policiers vont être brûlés et tué à
l'intérieur avec une volonté évidente de
tuer les policiers sortent ils ne tirent
même pas ils ne tirent même pas d'abord
parce qu'ils sont saisis dans une
position qui normalement devrait jamais
être on ne met pas des policiers en
position statique dans des quartiers qui
sont aussi d'entre eux et en plus tout
simplement sans doute aussi parce qu'ils
savent que s'ils tirent le danger pour
eux c'est qu'ensuite c'est eux qui
seront traînés devant la justice le
danger pour un policier qui se défend en
france c'est que le cas de la légitime
défense est tellement compliqué que
c'est lui à l'arrivée qui risquent de se
retrouver accusé et depuis depuis qu'est
ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce qu'a
annoncé le premier ministre
mais on finit par ne même plus réagir
dans notre pays il a annoncé qu'on
allait offrir des tenues iny j'ai pour
les policiers pour qu'ils puissent avoir
un cocktail molotov qui leur tombent
dessus et qui brûle pas mais est-ce
qu'on se moque de nous c'est à dire en
gros ça veut dire quoi subir plutôt que
sévir faire le gros dos au lieu de
réagir et vous avez entendu parler de
compagnies de crs qu'on ne renvoyait
dans le quartier de la grande borne vous
avez entendu parler des squats de
policiers qu'on ne renvoyait pour aller
chercher à l'intérieur du quartier ceux
qui ont osé faire ça rien parce que
c'est la lâcheté parce que c'est la
démission parce qu'on a à faire un
gouvernement qui depuis cinq ans à
démembrer l'autorité des forces de
police parce qu'on a à faire un
gouvernement qui depuis cinq ans ne
connaît plus le mot de sanctions sauf
pour faire des déclarations tonitruantes
devant les médias leurs résultats
auxquels on est aujourd'hui c'est
l'aboutissement de tout ce système de
laxisme qui s'est mis en place avec
madame taubira qui s'est poursuivie avec
manuel valls qui ne fait que des
déclarations nous nous sommes du côté
des forces de l'ordre nous nous trompons
pas quand il ya des délinquants leur
place est en prison et quand il ya des
criminels comme ça on n'appelle pas ça
des sauvageons et on va les chercher
dans les quartiers parce que sinon il
n'y a plus la république
[Applaudissements]
et
je ne parle pas roger l'a si bien décrit
de l'effondrement de l'autorité du
président de la république
je vais vous dire c'est pas bon
c'est pas sain c'est pas simple du tout
vous savez
il a déclaré ce qu'il a déclaré sur les
magistrats
c'était sûrement indigne c'était
sûrement une erreur
mais on fait pas ensuite qu'il a fait on
fait pas ensuite la carpette ont fait
pas ensuite le tapis parce que à ce
moment là qu'elle est la parole du
président de la république quand il en
est au stade où il est obligé de
s'excuser platement en étant humiliée
devant tout le monde
ça ne peut pas être ça en france un
président de la république il y à une
époque on avait un président de la
république aujourd'hui françois hollande
il n'est pas payé pour le costume du
président de la république française
[Applaudissements]
alors mes amis nous
et je voudrais en n'étant pas trop long
parce que surtout ce qui est intéressant
dans ces rencontres et ces réunions
c'est que ce soit vous qui par nier
parce que moi j'ai besoin de vous
entendre et on a besoin d'entendre
comment vous percevez les choses comment
est ce que vous vous réagissez vous qui
est la substance le coeur de notre
famille politique et je voulais juste
vous donner ce qui est mon analyse
personnelle
en 2017 il faut pas revenir pour ne rien
faire
en 2017 si la droite revient au pouvoir
ça doit être pour faire le travail et ma
conviction personnelle c'est que le
problème de la droite c'est pas trop en
dire le problème de la droite c'est pas
d'être trop direct dans ses paroles le
problème de la droite c'est d'être
courageux dans les faits c'est d'aller
jusqu'au bout de nos convictions quand
on est aux responsabilités et quand on
est au pouvoir et la question que se
posent
l'ensemble des personnes c est ce que
vous aurez le courage d'aller jusqu'au
bout et c'est cette question là qui
compte et moi ma préoccupation c'est que
notre famille politique joue le rôle de
la boussole à droite qu'on s'assure que
on commence pas dès la campagne à
s'excuser de nos valeurs et de nos idées
que l'on commence pas déjà dans notre
programme a donné le sentiment on est de
droite mais vous savez on n'est pas
tellement de droite que ça et on est
même capable d'être à gauche et donc on
est gentil on est généreux parce qu'on a
quand même un petit peu de coeur à
gauche et ben non moi je suis à droite
je suis fier des valeurs de la droite je
suis fier des convictions qui sont les
nôtres et je n'ai pas l'intention qu'on
s'en excuse
[Applaudissements]
pas s'en excuser qu'est ce que ça
signifie
ça signifie qu'on revenant il faudra
qu'on soit courageux
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'en revenant
il faut qu'on soit au clair ça n'est pas
la rue qui dictera sa loi à la majorité
du pays ça n'est pas la cgt qui nous
dictera ce qu'on a le droit de dire ou
ce qu'on n'a pas le droit de faire il
faut qu'on soit nous l'expression de
cette majorité silencieuse du pays qui
ne supportent plus quand il ya trois
défilés de manifestants avec quatre
banderoles où on se retrouve avec un
pouvoir politique lâche qui démissionne
les français veulent le changement la
question qui se pose à la classe
politique et notamment à nous est ce
qu'on continue à être lâche ou est ce
qu'on a le courage de faire le travail
c'est pas la rue qui commande en france
si on veut redresser notre pays
il faudra que nous ayons le courage de
revenir sur les lois qui ont été
adoptées par les socialistes quand les
socialistes sont au pouvoir ils ne se
privent pas pour revenir sur les lois
que nous nous avons fait et bien je
n'aurais aucun état d'âme à revenir sur
un certain nombre de lois qui ont été
adoptées par les socialistes et qui
aboutissent aujourd'hui à nous mettre
dans le mur je ne veux pas qu'on
continue à démissionner et puis
et puis
pour finir c'est avec notre famille
politique qu'il faut réformer c'est avec
les membres de notre famille politique
qu'il faut réformer si en allant
jusqu'au bout de nos idées qu'il faut le
faire ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
pour moi quelque chose qui est très
simple on a un pays qu'il faut remettre
la tête à l'endroit
ça veut dire que tout ce qui est à mi
parcours tout ce qui est du filet d'eau
tiède
tout ce qui est des demies compromis ne
permettra pas de réveiller le pays moi
je ne crois pas que la france soit
fragile
je ne crois pas que les français aient
peur je ne crois pas qu'ils demandent
surtout qu'on bouge 1/2 bout de curseur
quelque part regardez à quoi on est
réduit aujourd'hui la politique on a des
techniciens aux petits pieds à chaque
fois qu'on met une proposition sur la
table gouvernement nous dit la
constitution ne le permet pas la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme ne le permet pas la loi
remet pas le décret ne le permet pas le
conseil constitutionnel ne le
supporterait pas le conseil d'état la
censure et c'est une politique qui a
démissionné ce sont des élus qui n'ont
plus le courage de renverser les tables
et d'aller de l'avant et de redonner du
souffle si vous votez si vous vous
engagez c'est pas pour ensuite envoyer
des fonctionnaires à l'assemblée
nationale qui n'ont plus le courage de
leurs idées c'est les élus qui doivent
commander c'est pas l'administration qui
doit décider et on a besoin d'avoir des
élus qui vont au bout de leurs
convictions quand le général de gaulle
arrive en 1958 il ne se pose pas la
question de savoir si c'est possible ou
pas possible il le fait c'est ce souffle
que je veux qu'on retrouve dans la
politique française le souffre d'avoir
le courage de dire c'est nous qui
décidons nous ne sommes pas là pour être
des clercs de notaire on est là pour
changer le contenu du pays lui redonner
un souffle et une flamme et pas pour se
contenter d'appliquer les textes de loi
si vous votez pour des élus c'est pour
changer la loi et pas pour être la
besogneuse mans incapable de redonner ce
nouveau souffle au pays
[Applaudissements]
alors un nouveau souffle ça veut dire
réhabiliter le travail évidemment c'est
pour moi la mère de toutes les réformes
quand dans un pays celui qui travaillent
gagnent à peine plus que si ray chez lui
ça ne peut pas marcher quand dans un
pays vous donner tous à ceux qui ne font
rien et rien à ce qu'ils font tout ça ne
peut pas fonctionner vous savez hier
j'étais dans les vosges
dans une rencontre notamment avec des
membres de notre famille politique et
puis il ya quelqu'un qui était venue
exprès pour me voir qui restaurateurs
sept salariés et qui dit monsieur
wauquiez cherche à embaucher cinq
personnes se trouvent personne
et c'est pas que les gens sont fainéants
c'est qu'ils viennent me voir et me
disent mais monsieur remis regardez ce
que je gagne en travaillant chez vous si
je reste chez moi ce cumul le rsa l'apl
les différentes aides je fais un peu de
travail au noir un peu d'extra le
week-end mais je gagne plus qu'en pensez
vous je gagne quasiment 300 euros de
plus il m'a montré un courrier de
quelqu'un qui lui avait fait le calcul
300 euros de plus moi je reproche pas
aux semble pas aller travailler dans ces
conditions ce que je reproche c'est nous
nous qui n'avons pas le courage de
secouer ce système de l'assistanat alors
oui vous le savez ça fait partie de nos
batailles et de nos convictions que je
porte avec une détermination sans faille
ça signifie
ça signifie que quand quelqu'un est au
rsa on doit systématiquement lui
demander en contrepartie des heures de
travail d'intérêt général parce que
c'est le meilleur service à lui rendre
pour le remettre sur le chemin du
travail
et ça signifie évidemment qu'on doit
empêcher le cumul des prestations
sociales qui permettrait de dépasser le
niveau du smic parce que sinon on a la
tête à l'envers et que le pays ne peut
pas fonctionner vous n'aidez pas celui
qui est aux prestations sociales vous
découragez celui qui travaillent quels
que soient les prestations sociales ça
ne doit jamais pouvoir dépasser les
trois quarts du smic et encore c'est
déjà beaucoup il faut que le travail
paye et ça signifie
qu'il faut aussi qu'on s'attaque à la
question des retraites
parce que dans la réhabilitation du
travail quand vous avez quelqu'un qui a
travaillé pendant toute sa vie et qui se
retrouvent avec une toute petite
retraite
parfois plus faible que quelqu'un qui
n'a pas travaillé que ce soit d'ailleurs
quelqu'un qui a travaillé ou quelqu'un
qui a élevé ses enfants quand on a un
système dans lequel parfois quelqu'un
qui travaille dur se retrouve à la fin
avec un régime de retraite qui est plus
petit que celui qui a un régime spécial
de retraite ça ne peut pas fonctionner
ça veut dire que si on veut remettre à
léquilibre l'ensemble de nos régimes de
retraite il ya une seule réforme il faut
mettre à égalité le public et le privé
il faut supprimer tous les régimes
spéciaux de retraite
mais tous les régimes
et là vous allez voir ce qu'ils vont le
plus applaudir c'est philippe et roger
sait y compris les régimes spéciaux de
retraites des parlementaires
parce que si on veut supprimer
parce que pourquoi je vous le dis les
politiques sont pas des profiteurs les
politiques gagnent pas des fortunes les
politiques travaillent et travaillent
dur mais si jamais vous voulez pouvoir
réformer il faut s'appliquer à soi-même
ce qu'on demande aux autres moi je veux
qu'on supprime le régime spécial de
retraite des cheminots et ben si je veux
supprimer le régime spécial de retraite
des cheminots il faut pouvoir supprimer
le régime spécial de retraite des
parlementaires parce que sinon ça ne
passera jamais on s'applique à soi même
ce qu'on demande aux autres
[Applaudissements]
et puis je vais aussi le dire exactement
comme je le pense
on ne peut pas continuer à avoir d'un
côté des toutes petites retraites et de
l'autre côté des gens qui arrivent en
france sans même avoir cotisé et qu'ils
bénéficient de notre solidarité
nationale du jour au lendemain ça ne
peut pas fonctionner on ne peut pas
avoir d'un côté
on ne peut pas avoir d'un côté des
retraites de misère on nous explique
qu'on n'a pas les moyens de les
réhabiliter et de l'autre côté des
retraites qui sont offerts à des gens
qui n'ont jamais travaillé sur le sol
français alors je le dis très simplement
et ça vaut d'ailleurs sur l'ensemble de
notre système social il faut revenir
dessus on ne peut pas continuer avec
l'aide médicale d'état on ne peut pas
continuer avec le dire avec le
déroutement de la cmu qui est en réalité
utilisé aussi pour camoufler une partie
des aides médicales qui sont offertes à
des personnes qui sont en situation
irrégulière ou à des demandeurs d'asile
on ne peut pas continuer avec un système
de minimum vieillesse qui est offert à
des gens qui n'ont pas suffisamment
cotisé quand on vient en france c'est
pour travailler et pas pour bénéficier
d'un régime de sécurité sociale prix est
beaucoup trop généreux
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais enfin mes amis avant de vous
laisser la parole conclure avec quelque
chose qui est pour moi très important
notre pays on le voit bien dans une
crise identitaire
notre pays on le voit bien est soumis à
une pression d'un islam politique et
intégristes qui non seulement ne dit pas
on refuse de s'adapter à la france mais
qui est là pour demander à la france de
s'adapter à lui ce qui est inacceptable
face à tout ça pendant trop longtemps
notamment sous la pression de la gauche
on a pratiqué un discours de circulez ya
rien à voir dans les quartiers pas de
problème quand on parle de l'islam
oulala surtout pas d' amalgame dans des
trains y'a pas de soucis la france c'est
le règne de la tolérance et de la
diversité à tel point que à force
d'avoir ces mots plein la bouche on
finit par plus inciter chacun à opposer
sa différence aux autres plutôt que
d'apprendre ce que nous avons en commun
la république c'est pas ça et le
terrorisme pour moi est aussi
l'aboutissement de ces démissions
successives de ses lâchetés successives
de ce qu'incarne najat vallaud belkacem
quand elles des membres
quand elles des membres l'enseignement
de l'histoire
quand elles abouti a expliqué que chacun
doit venir avec sa langue d'origine sa
diversité au lieu d'apprendre le
français et d' apprendre l'orthographe
quand on aboutit au fond à une france
qui donne le sentiment d'avoir honte la
promesse de la république française ça
n'était pas ça la promesse de la
république française et il ya dans cette
salle des gens que je connais et qui en
sont le reflet c'était des gens et on a
été aussi construit par ceux là qui
venaient de l'étranger mais qui venaient
de l'étranger en disant à leurs enfants
mon fils ma fille tu viens dans un beau
pays tu viens dans un pays qui porte nos
valeurs des belles valeurs tu viens dans
un pays qu'il faut aimer et chérir et tu
viens dans un pays qui est ton pays un
pays qui nous donne la possibilité de
réussir est un pays qui devient
maintenant notre pays notre culture
notre langue et notre histoire des
familles qui disaient à leurs enfants tu
dois devenir plus français que les
français si nous en sommes là
aujourd'hui c'est parce que ça fait trop
longtemps qu'on s'excuse c'est parce que
ça fait trop longtemps qu'on dénigre
nous mêmes notre langue notre culture et
notre histoire je suis fier de la france
je suis fier de sa culture
je suis fier de sa langue je suis fier
de sa littérature la france est une
belle promesse la france est une belle
nation la france est une belle
république je veux qu'à l'occasion de
2017 nous retrouvions la fierté de ce
qu'est notre pays pour que la france
réussisse elle ne doit pas renoncer à ce
qu'elle est elle doit retrouver ce
qu'elle est et c'est ça la promesse de
notre retour au pouvoir vive la france
et vive la république
[Applaudissements]